pour attirer les motards il faut des
paysages des routes avec des virages et
un endroit vraiment accueillons pour
planter sa tente
voilà le projet de laurent cherrier
motards et gérants de campings tout est
prêt l'idée c'est de se rencontrer puis
d'échanger m6 on a conçu un espace un
peu confort qu'on va aller visiter
puisqu'un ben quand on part en randonnée
en moto on n'a pas beaucoup de matériel
donc ça c'est l'espace cuisine abri
collectif abri a partagé avec tables
chaises tout ce qu'il faut pour un pas
faire à manger on a les frigos qui sont
branchés en permanence les réchauds la
vaisselle aujourd'hui en fait mené chez
moi à vous n'êtes pas de moto
la moto vous attend sur le camping alors
décline tout le produit avec les casques
et les gants etc
et finalement ça parle à peine motards
avec quelques copains aussi passionné
que lui le jeune chef d'entreprise a
créé des itinéraires pour découvrir le
pays des châteaux
à peine sorti du camping le château de
cheverny son musée tintin et ses jardins
sont 1 km les gens connaissent la région
mais parler les grands axes et nous ce
qu'on est bien accommodé du coin et
qu'on connaît bien la région voulu faire
découvrir ces petites routes les
châteaux qui sont sur le bord des routes
les petits coins sympas l'occasion de
découvrir le plus petit des châteaux de
la loire et de rencontrer sa
propriétaire qui habite résumé de
l'architecturé du val de loire
vous avez d abord il ya une atmosphère
très personnelles et humaines
et c'est vrai qu'on aime recevoir les
gens c'est pas un projet commercial
c'est un projet qui a une dimension
artistique amicales familiales
esthétique et de partage
voilà le détour par chambord est
incontournable
les plus beaux points de vue sur le
monument s'offre depuis la route au
motard saint-dié le port de chambord est
juste à côté
retour au camping par les bords de loire
pour finir la journée en beauté